hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a halloween video review and a video
that i can promise you is going to be
pretty unique to this channel in fact i
promise you this is the only ios app
review you'll probably see in 2010 on
the mkbhd youtube channel which
definitely means it's worth something so
without any further ado let's take a
look this application is called wiki
golf and it's based on a really popular
concept where basically you visit a
wikipedia page and you use links on that
wikipedia page to get to a certain other
wikipedia page in a certain amount of
clicks so i have it installed on this
ios device and i won't even tell you the
name of it you can probably figure that
out but it's really a well-polished and
well-made game and can provide quite a
bit of entertainment
for the on sale price right now of just
one dollar and i know some of you have
already clicked out of this video
thinking you don't want to pay to play
wiki golf but stay tuned this review
might change your mind like any other
app review like i do on the droid dog
youtube channel for android applications
i show the settings of the application
but ready really that's just the how to
play section and like i explained
earlier it's just like going from hole
to hole basically on wikipedia so hole
one you have to get to the european
union and when it says par four if
you've ever played golf that means you
have four clicks to get to the european
union it'll start you off on some random
obscure thing
you might not have heard of row but
you'll have to get to four
four clicks to get to the european union
basically if you get it in three clicks
that's obviously one under par birdie
four clicks is par five clicks is a
bogey if you ever forget what your
target is or just don't know what the
european union is i don't know how
that's possible uh that you can go ahead
and click the name at the top like i
just showed you and it'll give you a
little picture from the wikipedia
definition at the bottom it'll also tell
you how many strokes you've taken and
the amount of strokes you have for par
so right off the bat i have no idea how
to get out of road to europe so i'll
just click the first thing and we'll see
where that takes us so you can see here
is that we've taken our first shot and
basically everything in blue which is
clickable that is a link to another
wikipedia page is an opportunity for a
second shot you can scroll down and
expand all the subcategories in the
bottom to find a whole bunch more links
and there's a whole bunch of popular
places where people like to find links
like in history uh there might be a
bunch of countries named or there might
be something you need to get to that
that's in the functions section or
something like that so there's a lot of
a lot of cheats people like to use to
get to things quickly and to get a
really low score
there's also a search function at the
bottom right hand corner which really
makes playing a game a lot more fun
basically you can search any term so
i'll go ahead and search country here
and it'll go ahead and highlight every
single time it uses the word country in
that article unfortunately it doesn't
use the word country in this word uh in
this article so i'll try a number of
other terms but you can't actually use
the arrow to get to the next highlighted
word you actually have to scroll to get
to the next highlight so it's not really
cheating it just helps point out words
you need to see more easily
so you can see on our next shot here
we've gotten to the page about dna and i
feel like there's going to be some
scientists here who made some
contributions towards dna that was from
europe so i guess that was a pretty good
choice i wonder if any of these guys
here were european also note that you
can't click on the picture because it
leads to outside of wikipedia so you
actually have to click on that blue link
like i mentioned earlier to get to the
next hole or to the next stroke
all alright so in the end here after we
finished the game and finished the last
hole obviously i did terribly on the
last hole but you can see that i got a
total of 44 which was five under par so
i'm so proud of myself um and i actually
do want to share this score because i've
never actually finished a full nine
holes before so you can go ahead and
submit now once you submit your score
globally it will be under your name and
also when i do this video here there's
obviously not much
people have played but when you go now a
whole bunch of people more than 70
people in fact are on the global
leaderboards that you can view just with
a single touch so that's really cool
that you cannot view that
overall it's cool that this game can be
played on an ipod touch when there's
wi-fi and i gotta say it's the only ios
only game that i've actually become
addicted to since angry birds came to
android sadly enough i just discovered
that game yesterday anyway until next
time this has been mkbhd with a scary
ios halloween app review and until next
time talk to you later peace